it was a mystery at Lake Mead since the
1970s nearly 50 years later the eight
news now investigators have obtained
original documents from when one man
disappeared eight news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy brings us a story of what
happened to Donald Smith
it gets vanished during a boat ride at
Lake Mead near Colville Bay nearly 50
years later after the dramatic drop in
the water level divers find his remains
in the same area I think there are a lot
more to be discovered Larry Millwood
owns third reef divers in Henderson
offering training
but we don't come out here actually
looking for anything
but if we do happen to come across
something
um you know we'll mark it and then let
the authorities know he and fellow diver
Mitchell clafey say they haven't
personally found any remains I've heard
a lot of mob stories and stuff like that
discoveries they have made include
weapons I don't think it surprises me
with the past that's gone on here turns
out when Smith vanished The
Disappearance of several weapons also
became part of the investigation here's
what unfolded according to these
documents we obtained some of them hand
written by Rangers at the scene Smith's
wife said he left home around one in the
afternoon with his boat after drinking
but he wasn't drunk he had put his
shotgun into the cabin of the boat and
had also taken his handgun two long time
friends set about two hours later while
they were about 150 feet away from Smith
and his boat they saw him fall backward
off the back of the boat with his hands
thrown up and about 60 seconds later
they arrived at the scene saw one deck
shoe floating in the water and even
after diving in they couldn't find Smith
Park Service investigators arrived and
found no sign of Smith and no weapons on
the boat or in his vehicle since those
two friends were first on the scene
Rangers suspected they may know
something about those weapons both said
they were willing to take a lie detector
test investigators later concluded no
one would have been able to hide the
weapons since Rangers were at the scene
they determined the guns were likely
stolen from Smith's vehicle since it was
left unlocked and it was a common
occurrence year diverse searched that
day and the next eventually determining
the water was too deep the Park Service
didn't have enough resources and the
exact location where Smith drowned was
unknown investigators in the 70s
concluded Donald Smith either slipped or
was knocked off balance by a wave and
because of the combination of the cold
water and the breath being knocked out
of him that's why there were no bubbles
in the water and immediately no sign of
him the National Park Service tells us
more human remains have been found at
Lake Mead
on October 17th of last year a diver
found a human bone in the mud near the
fuel dock at Colville Bay over the next
couple of days Park Service divers
returned and found a pair of jeans with
multiple bones buried in the mud along
with a wallet and credit cards belonging
to Donald P Smith the maximum depth
reported at the time 47 feet while
divers in 1974 reported water as deep as
160 feet it's changed Larry Millwood
knows well with the movement and the
water levels coming down you just never
know what to expect Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now